thomas c'est un petit garçon que
j'aimais profondément près de deux ans
après le suicide de son fils thomas
alexandre taillefer tente de comprendre
mais surtout de faire oeuvre utile parce
que les gens ici qui ont déjà fait une
tentative de suicide
l'homme d'affaires ne souhaitait pas se
mettre de l'avant dans ce documentaire
et pourtant je dois vous avouer que
c'est très très du cices très dur de
regarder sur ce que c'est très personnel
en même temps de personnifier ce combat
là je pense que ça amène des munitions
et ça va permettre de rendre le tout
plus efficace alors je le vois un peu
comme le testament de thomas quelque
chose
le titre buy vient de l'ultime message
laissé par te ment à ses parents elle
c'est un post it sur son ordinateur sur
lequel est écrit à rien
vous auriez laissé de plus mais ça ne
représentait tellement avec tous ces
enjeux communicationnel tous ces enjeux
de sociabilisation doit tout avait écrit
une lettre pis ça a été ça a déclenché
un processus long et ont amené avec ce
documentaire alexandre taillefer veut
traiter de santé mentale et surtout
faire changer les choses
ce que je veux surtout généré c'est
justement une réflexion profonde sur le
système de santé mentale et comment
est-ce qu'on doit la dre sait comment
est-ce qu'on peut donner accès plus
rapidement plus facilement et ça n'a pas
de bon sens qu'on n'est pas priorisées
aujourd'hui ce segment le nom de système
de santé il est temps qu'on se réveille
aujourd'hui
le documentaire sera présenté sur toutes
les plateformes de radio-canada à la
télé et à la radio simultanément mardi
soir prochain et on dirait que sur la
page facebook ici radio canada telus
j'espère que beaucoup de familles qui
vont regarder ce documentaire l'ensemble
des enfants des filles mais je ne fais
des jeunes hommes qui ont regardé ce
avec leurs parents ici certains
dialogues qui peuvent être initiés tant
mieux le jeu vidéo ici mélanie
boissonneault radio canada montréal